- Thank you and may
God bless America.
(audience clapping)
- All right, please, sir,
a couple introductions and
we'll get you out of here.
This is John O'Rourke.
- Nice to meet you, John.
- Mr. Ian Roberts.
- Nice to meet you.
- Peter Atencio.
- All right, nice to meet you.
- Jerome Smith.
- Come on, bro.
What's up fam?
You know this.
- Heath Williamson.
- Nice to meet you, all right.
- Mary Woodbury.
- Nice to meet you.
- Jay Martel.
- Nice to meet you, sir.
- Tasha Robinson.
- Come on, come on, come on.
Hmm, hmm, hmm.
Feel that? Can you feel it?
- Emily George.
- Nice to meet you.
- Darryl Stokes.
- Come on, what's up fam?
How you doin'?
- All right.
- Never forget about that,
'cause that's all we got!
Nice to meet you.
All right.
Ah, bring it in, bring it in!
Started from the
bottom, now we're here!
- Yeah!
- Nice to meet you, all right.
Nice to meet you, all right.
Nice to meet...
- 1/8th Black.
- Afternoon my octoroon!
Come on, bring it in there.
- All right.
- Tuck that.
- I'm in there dawg.
- You tuckin' it in there?
- I'm in there.
- Whatutuckdawg.
- You chop, chop, chop.
- I'm in there.
'Cause I'm in there.
I'm in there.
- All right.
- Nice to meet you, man.
Nice to meet you.
Oh my goodness, look at this.
Oh, she is so beautiful, mmm.
I want another one.
There you go, precious,
beautiful, beautiful.
What's her name?
- Oh, this is Livia Rougie.
- Okay, nice to meet you
Miss Rougie, all right.
Now come on.
There he is, boom!
- Mr. President.
- All right, man!
Good to meet you!
All right.
- Here we go.
Right this way, sir.